Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Spielst du eigentlich auch?
Aber wenn du spielen würdest, was würde man über dich herausfinden können.
Weiß ich nicht. Also weiß, weiß ich echt nicht. Sorry.
Logbuchnetzpolitik, da sind wir wieder. Einen schönen Freitag haben wir uns ausgesucht, einen schönen Morgen. Ja, so muss, man muss passiert. Nö, oder?
Ich war äh ich war am Wochenende bei einer Konferenz war ich als Gast. Rein reiner Gast.
Ein reiner Gast. Bei Einbruch der Dunkelheit, wenn ich das äh richtig sehe.
Theorie und Praxis der Selbstermächtigung in Zeiten digitaler Kontrolle.
So eine Veranstaltung kam so ein bisschen so von der Seite, äh wurde irgendwie erst wenig drüber geredet und dann war sie auf einmal so da.
Ich bin froh, dass du es ansprichst, weil die war die kamen halt wirklich irgendwie von der Seite, ne? Das war irgendwie,
die wurde offenbar von Menschen gemacht, die irgendwie jetzt nicht so in dieser Szene normalerweise drin sind,
und irgendwie auch von der Kulturstiftung des Bundes irgendwie gefördert und in der Berliner äh Volksbühne abgehalten,
Das war irgendwie alles so nicht die üblichen Verdächtigen, was wir erstmal gar nicht so schlecht ist. Finde ich auch ein interessantes Zeichen, dass jetzt.
Plötzlich tatsächlich irgendwie na ja so Internet und Kramkonferenzen.
Von Leuten, die jetzt weder ähm sage ich mal äh als als Hacker äh einschlägig bekannt sind noch als politische Parteien,
äh verdächtig sind, weil jetzt so so wirklich eine politische Internetkonferenz.
Ja, also ich würde das jetzt nicht unbedingt als neu, aber vielleicht als Revival äh bezeichnen. Man ist ja so Berliner Gazette, so ist auch
so ein bisschen so ein Projekt, was ich so ein bisschen der Begleitung der der der Netzkulturellen Aspekte äh verschrieben hat und in vielerlei äh Veranstaltungen auch schon ähm ja, öffentlich auch abgefeiert hat.
Stimmt deren deren Einfluss habe ich da jetzt irgendwie grade.
Aber vielleicht erinnerst du dich, es gab ja vor langer, langer, langer Zeit äh schon zum Beispiel The Wizard of Oz, die Wisard of OS von Volker äh Grasmuck, ja, die ein paar mal stattgefunden hat.
Mhm. OS da dann für Open Source, ne, oder war das für Operatings? Ist.
Ja
Glaube ich.
Glaube, dass ja, weiß ich gar nicht, wie zweideutig das vielleicht gemeint gewesen ist
Aber auf jeden Fall hat er sich sehr viel eben früh schon mit dem Open Source äh Phänomen, aber eben auch freies Wissen et cetera. Also so ein bisschen so eine Prä-Wikipedia, äh Pre, Copyright Nord schon,
da wurde schon die Debatte im Prinzip dort auch geführt. Und ich würde sagen, das war noch ein bisschen vergleichbare Kreise. Ich konnte jetzt leider zu dieser Veranstaltung nicht kommen,
Wurde auch schwierig gewesen, weil die war dann auch ausverkauft, weil sie nicht in der Volksbühne selber also nicht in einem großen Saal stattfand, sondern nur in den Räumen nebenan. Und sie war dann irgendwie hoffnungslos überlaufen, weil sie ja äh vollgespickt war mit ähm,
bekannten und weniger Bekannten Protagonisten der letzten äh Wochen, ja, also viele Leute, die auf dem Kongress gesprochen haben, waren da,
und noch einige mehr, die auch schon früher mal auf Kongressen.
Ja und dann aber dann teilweise irgendwie gemischt mit irgendwelchen Universitätsprofessoren zum Thema so und so,
die dann irgendwie teilweise sehr abgefahrenen Kram gemacht haben, weil sie irgendwie meinten sie, er wäre jetzt Philosophieprofessoren und müssten ihm was erzählen, was,
keinen direkten Bezug zum zum geschehen hat.
Deine Verwirrung wird kommen.
Alter. Ähm und was, also das diesem, diesem die Mischung der Leute war schon irgendwie.
Zu zu durcheinander irgendwie. Also es war, da wurde halt zu viel zusammengegossen und dann aber trotzdem irgendwie nur, weiß ich nicht,
dreihundert äh äh Gäste oder sowas, weil sie das Ding nicht in Räumen großartig naja doch schon ja, es sind Räume. Äh an der an der Volksbühne gibt's einen langen Flur. Und der und ein Foyer,
Und das war quasi in diesem Foyer, fand diese äh Veranstaltung statt, ja. Und da sind dann irgendwie Leute aus den USA eingeflogen, um da irgendwie in diesem Foyer zu stehen,
oder hinten irgendwie äh ein größerer äh Theatersaal vermutet wurde, ja, den hat ja keiner gesehen, weil es alles irgendwie abgeschlossen war. Und äh der rote und grüne Salon, das sind ja auch allenfalls so ähm,
Empfangsräume oder sowas. Da das ja im Flur. Also das war von der Raumnutzung dieses Riesengebäudes irgendwie
nicht viel erschlossen und da war hätte man sehr locker äh sicherlich die dreifache Anzahl Besucher irgendwie auch versorgen können.
Ja, dann auch über Eintritt finanzieren können. Ist wahrscheinlich einfach etwas mutlos geplant worden. Das kann man vielleicht verstehen, wenn man da die Zahlen genau erkennen würde, die wir nicht kennen. Äh wie das eben so ist.
Jeden Fall hatten sie äh dort dann auch, was ich sehr, sehr großartig fand, äh Bruce Sterling, ein äh Science Fiction Autor,
der äh weiß ich nicht schon wohl sehr viel länger als ich äh irgendwie,
mir über solche Dinge Gedanken mache, sich darüber Gedanken macht. Und der begann mit einem großen Bewerter in seine Ansprache mit einem großen,
äh begonnen. Und oder,
Ich meine, der hat einfach nur provoziert. Also der hat sich im Prinzip auf die Bühne gestellt, er ist in Texaner, ja, er hat ja auch so dieser texanischen Art, wenn irgendwie seine Anfangsrede gemacht, hat sich dann irgendwie, man wusste nicht genau, ob der die Leute jetzt verarscht oder ernst nimmt,
über diese,
deutschen Autoren, die sich ja zusammengeschlossen haben zu diesem Kollektivautorenwriters, ergänzt äh Maße Vaylins, ja, da hat er sich dann irgendwie
er hat ja dann andauernd die Bilder von denen auf dem Bild auf dem Monitor gehabt und hat gefragt so interessante Menschen, habe ich noch nie gesehen und auch ein bisschen über die gespottet oder so, aber,
Er schloss dann so mit den Worten so äh what a you gonna do?
Und hat jetzt auch keine Antwort darauf geleistet, sich die auf diesem Podium da die ganze Zeit irgendwie darauf.
Versteift eben oder einfach so aus dieser Position gebracht so, was macht ihr denn jetzt so? Was macht ihr Deutschen denn jetzt hier so, wenn äh ich meine ähm,
Zitate waren die irgendwie so, dass er sagte so, ich meine, ihr habt doch die Erfahrung, wollt ihr mir jetzt als Deutsche erzählen, dass ihr keine Erfahrungen habt in äh in Massenüberwachung
wollt ihr mir als Deutsche erzählen, dass ihr keine Ahnung darin habt, ein bestehendes System zu erschüttern? Meint ihr die Revolution dieser Welt? Äh wurden irgendwie,
von der EU reguliert oder äh was ist jetzt hier los? Also es war schon echt, der war sehr provokativ, sehr ähm
auch herablassend gegenüber seinen anderen mitdiskutanten,
und äh das war äh also es war äh ich glaube keiner mochte ihn, ich war äh völlig begeistert.
Umso enttäuschter, als ich ihn dann nachher mal ansprach, zu seinen Gedanken, was denn nun zu tun sei, aber äh dass ähm,
können wir ja mal einspielen, weil ich habe ein paar Leute angesprochen, die so da waren.
Wen hast du denn alles angesprochen.
Ich habe angesprochen Jeremy Zimmermann von Lackfadra two dünet, der französischen, großen ähm,
Internet äh Bürgerrechts äh Vereinigung, die sich auch sehr viel auf der EU-Ebene einbringt.
Auch ein sehr bekannte äh Person. Ähm Bruce Sterling. Dann den ähm.
Nicht Miker, Mikasiffrey ist ein ähm mir noch bis dahin nicht näher bekannt gewesener äh Professor für Dinge,
aber oder oder untyp, also ehrlich gesagt wusste ich noch nicht mal wer das ist, aber er hat sich sehr, sehr äh kompetent geäußert zu verschiedenen äh Fragen und die äh Marina Weißband von der Piratenpartei.
Mhm. Okay, interessante Mischung. Hören wir mal rein.
Jeremy Zimmermann.
Hallo ähm.
Bruce Sterling.
Genau.
Mika Surfree, now.
Wow, ich finde,
ähm,
Tools für Communications.
Sensitive,
ähm,
ähm.
Marina Weißband, was muss jetzt geschehen?
Ähm ich denke, wir müssen jetzt gucken, wie wir konkret handeln können. Und zwar einerseits jeder von uns. Das bedeutet,
wir sollten den Geheimdiensten ihre Arbeit erschweren und möglichst teuer machen. Durch äh Kryptosoftware, durch möglichst viel Verschlüssel, durch dezentrale Netzwerke.
Und das Zweite ist, wir müssen politisch handeln. Das bedeutet, äh wir sollten einen internationalen Konsens finden, was Geheimdiensten nicht erlaubt ist,
äh zum Beispiel die Spionage der Bevölkerung eines Landes,
und wenn wir merken, dass wir das nicht überprüfen und nicht einhalten können, weil die Geheimdienste nun mal Geheim operieren,
dann passen Geheimdienste nicht in ein, nicht in demokratischen Staaten und dann sollten wir sie abschaffen.
Ja, klare Forderung, hm?
Ich fand das, ich fand das mal ganz interessant so zu hören. Also ich war natürlich von Bruce Sterling sehr enttäuscht.
Man muss ins Hotel.
Der muss jetzt halt ins Hotel dauern. Der hat auch die.
Der muss einen Tag leben auch.
Ich glaube, der hat auch die Eröffnungsrede bei der transmediale hier in Berlin äh gehalten. Also das ist äh das ist schon eigentlich ein gefragter Mensch. Also sein Auftritt da fand ich großartig. Ich weiß nicht, ob's da irgendwie eine Aufzeichnung von gibt, weil er wirklich, äh was er gemacht hat, ist halt auch mal so diese,
Hilflosigkeit auch wirklich mal vor Augen geführt, ja? Das fand ich sehr äh interessant, na ja, schade, dass er.
Kein guten Spruch auf den Lippen hatten, als du ihn angesprochen hast.
Ja Pech gehabt. Aber sonst, ich weiß nicht so, vielleicht äh kann man das ja auch mal kommentieren, ob das jetzt irgendwie reizvoll ist, sowas mal zu machen. Ich finde das ja immer ganz gut, wenn man andere Leute auch einfach mal die Möglichkeit gibt, so ihre Meinung äh darzulegen.
Ist ist natürlich eine fiese Frage, weil sie also super generell ist, ne?
Aber es gibt schon sehr unterschiedliche Auffassungen da drüber, was denn nun getan werden soll oder wer denn überhaupt in der Lage sei, irgendetwas äh zu tun, ja?
Ja auch so die Stimmen, die der Meinung sind, dass die die Techniker und die ganzen Netzkonstrukteure, Hacker und so weiter, da äh viel zu,
Ängste, nicht Tunnelblicklich, da äh auf das Thema zugehen. Ich muss aber sagen, auch noch etwas nachgrübeln,
Man sich mal anschaut, was eigentlich grade diese ganze Scheiße nach oben gebracht hat. Und wenn man sich mal anschaut, wo die Schutzräume sind.
Wo diese Leute, die das gemacht haben, irgendwie noch wirken können, dann bewegt sich das genau dort.
Also Systemadministratoren,
veröffentlichen. Diese Dokumente und sind ihre habhaft äh geworden, ja. Äh Wiki-Leaks hat sicherlich äh,
Projekt und als Idee sehr viel Weg äh bereitet oder auch konkret dazu beigetragen, Informationen nach draußen zu äh leiten. Und.
Meine was.
Alles so auf dem Kongress rumlief, ja? Also ich könnte mir gut vorstellen, dass der ein oder andere Geheimdienst da ganz gerne äh irgendwie mal einen Atompilz äh gesehen hätte über dem Kongresszentrum Hamburg, aber,
Ist halt jetzt nicht so ohne weiteres äh machbar, ja? Und wir können auch ganz froh sein, dass wir noch in einer Situation äh leben,
in Deutschland zumindest, wo sagen wir mal, ein ähm übergebührliches staatliches Durchgreifen in die Strukturen des und um den CCC herum,
absolut unvorstellbar wäre. Ja, ich meine, dann hätten wir wirklich sofort eine Mülltonne äh und mehr. Ähm und,
Das ist halt auch schon ein Ergebnis dieser Szene. Ne, ich will das nicht überhöhen. Ich will, dass da auch kein kein Heldenstatus draus zimmern, sondern nur einfach mal so den Blick nur auf ein paar äh,
denken und ich finde das schon ein äh und letzten Endes sind eben auch viele der Überlegungen, die jetzt von allen getätigt werden. Viele der grundsätzlichen Hinterfragungen, ja,
Das ist halt einfach die Thematik, die schon äh sehr lange vorherrscht. Auf dem zweiundzwanzig C drei.
Vor acht Jahren haben Frank, Rieger und Rob Conrap, den Fieber damals schon vielbeachteten Vortrag gehalten,
wo sie im Wesentlichen genau das gesagt haben, was äh jetzt halt äh in jeder Tageszeitung drinsteht, ja?
Sagen wir mal die Szene selber so ein bisschen ungläubig dastand und so ein bisschen so hey nie und so das ist jetzt hier nur ja äh passt schon und so, was ja dann auch durchaus, sagen wir mal,
der Folge auch zu so einer Wiederbelebung führte. Also es war schon so auch äh ne, es kam ja dann so mal wieder ein paar Erfolge mit den Wahlcomputern und so weiter, aber das ist natürlich im
In der Skala der der Gesamt des digitalen Gesamtverbrechen dann äh eine relativ kleine äh kleine Schlacht,
Naja, gut. Das ähm vielleicht dazu. Ähm ja, Marina Weißband,
Ja, man könnte ja mal den Geheimdiensten versuchen, einen Riegel vorzuschieben und wenn das nicht klappt, dann müsste man sie abschaffen. Schön gesagt, ähm.
Nicht so richtig. Allerdings ist dieser Punkt mit ähm Überwachung teuer machen, finde ich,
Ist denn eigentlich eine ganz gute These, so und da lässt sich sicherlich noch eine ganze Menge drehen,
Dass man ähm sehr wohl, dass die Überwachbarkeit erschwert, ja.
Ja
also alles äh ich das Problem ist und da ist ja dann der äh der Bruce Sterling ja sogar auch so versöhnlich, dass er sagt so, ey am Ende muss einfach jeder,
tun, was irgendwie in seiner Macht steht,
ja, wenn man das jetzt mal sehr wohlwollend interpretiert, was er da sagt. Und wahrscheinlich wird die ganze Sache jetzt nicht nur von den ähm von den Techleuten gelöst und nicht nur von den Politikern gelöst, aber ähm.
Nee, sie muss schon auch zu so einem zu einer gesamtgesellschaftlichen Bewegung kommen oder in gewisser Hinsicht dann auch zu einem Konsens und ob das wirklich stattfinden wird, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht,
Manchmal denkt man ja mal, kann, kann nicht sein, dann gibt's wieder so Momente, wo man sich umdreht und sagt, so wie der Innenminister hat jetzt gerade gesagt, die Amerikaner riechen nach äh Lulu, so, ja. Äh wie es hier gerade wieder über die Bildschirme huscht,
was auch so ein Statement ist, wo wir dachten, das hätte ja auch vor einem halben Jahr schon mal fallen können. Und dann dachten wir so, jetzt fällt's aber wirklich überhaupt nicht mehr. Da sitzen die aus,
Jetzt werden sie irgendwie auch schon mal wieder so ein bisschen stinkig, zumindest auf der Sicherheitskonferenz in München.
Die ja nicht irgendeine Veranstaltung ist, sondern das ist so der Ort, wo wirklich,
tough talk im Security-Bereich den internationalen geführt wird, so. Also keine Ahnung,
dieses selber tun. Ich fand auch in gewisser Hinsicht, wer hat das jetzt gesagt? Dieser Mika, das ähm.
Mal in seiner eigenen Organisation, sprich Firma, äh doch mal die Frage stellen soll, was,
Was tragen wir eigentlich dazu bei so, warum ist unsere Webseite nicht über HTPS erreichbar? Warum
verwenden wir diese und jene Technologie noch, warum speichern wir unsere Daten denn an der Hersteller? Was haben wir denn überhaupt für Prozeduren für unsere eigenen,
Ja, also wie gehen wir selber mit Daten um, wie gehen wir selber mit unserer Kommunikation um.
Das ist sicherlich schon was machen und das das ist ja auch das Interessante, ja, dass letzten Endes diese ganze Geschichte und da sind wir dann auch schon fast beim nächsten äh Thema.
Fast, dass äh und auch da stimmt wieder Marinas Aussage, ja, dieses teuer machen äh hat auch was damit zu tun, mit,
äh mit ökonomischen Folgen
Und in den USA gibt's, glaube ich, schon eine ganze Menge äh Stress zwischen der Regierung und den Geheimdiensten auf der einen Seite und äh Silicon Valley und natürlich auch anderen Wirtschaftszweigen auf der anderen Seite
einfach natürlich ihre Fälle davonschwimmen sehen in Bezug auf Vertrauen gegenüber den USA
ja? Ich meine es war so lange eine Selbstverständlichkeit, man fühlte sich in gewisser Hinsicht auch langer Zeit recht
wohl bei dem Gedanken, dass das Internet im Prinzip so seine Heimat in den USA hat, also nicht nur da herkommt, sondern das ist auch, sag mal, von der Infrastruktur her
da ist, ja, dass da,
viel Leitungen sind und so weiter und Freedom of Speed und bla bla bla. Diese ganzen äh grundlegenden Sachen. Wir hatten ja schon hier diese Debatte.
Ja diese Versuche der der internationalen Staatengemeinschaft,
über so Organisationen wie die ITU quasi so äh das Zepter äh über das Internet in die Hand zu bekommen
Ne, also quasi das Ganze so als Telefonnetz auf einmal zu verstehen und eben der ITU da quasi die Gestaltungs äh Fähigkeit zu geben. Dazu ist es nicht gekommen und das hat eben auch,
mit amerikanischer Internetkultur zu tun. Aber,
Jetzt kippt das halt einfach. Jetzt äh jetzt sind diese Unternehmen da und und schauen halt so die äh Regierungen von der Seite fragend an, sagen sie mal
hm, geht's noch, ja? Apple veröffentlicht zur Pressemitteilung mit so einem, ja, nö, irgendwie, all die bösen Hacker sollen bei uns keine Chance haben.
Ja und reden und redet aber auch nur von denen und äh schließt quasi implizit in dieser Meldung auch so die Regierung mit rein, ja? So nach dem Motto, wir betrachten diese Geheimdienste als als äh böse Angreifer,
Haben sie nicht gesagt, sondern ich weiß gar nicht, ob sie original Formulierung war. Also.
Es ist, es ist ein Wirtschaftsding, es ist ein Geldding und das ist halt tatsächlich das, was letzten Endes äh die Sache in Bewegung bringt, weil wenn nämlich auf einmal große Unternehmen, ja, von denen wir einfach wissen, welchen Einfluss sie auf die Politik haben, anfangen äh zu sehen, dass ihre Fälle davonschwimmen,
Dann gehen die halt zu diesen Politikern und sagen ähm, hallo? Uns geht da gerade irgendwie pinke Flöten und zwar so und so vielstellig.
Könnt ihr mal bitte könnt ihr da mal was machen, ja? Weil sonst gibt's nächsten Monat auch nicht wieder äh die monatliche Zuweisung, so,
dann bewegen sich die Dinge nämlich auf einmal wieder.
Also ja, natürlich also es sind schon Gedanken, die eine die eine die eine Rolle spielen, dann wird jetzt sehen, welche am Ende.
Ob die ausreichend sind. Weißt du, ob ob jetzt nur dieser Druck auf diese Unternehmen wirklich ausreichend ist? Ich meine, Deutschland,
es war ja, ich hatte das ja in dem, in dem Vortrag auch behandelt und man sieht's auch jetzt gerade, ich will das gar nicht hier in der Sendung großartig thematisieren, aber man sieht jetzt, wie deutsche Cloud-Anbieter da irgendwie jetzt gerade sehen,
Okay, krass, jetzt haben wir endlich nochmal eine Chance, ja, dass also die,
aus der anderen Seite darauf blicken und im Prinzip genau den gleichen Mist dann hier den Leuten andrehen wollen. Das heißt, so diesen wirklichen kulturellen Wandel, den sehe ich da jetzt nicht wirklich, ne.
Ja gut, vielleicht jetzt nicht unbedingt bei deutschen Telekommunikationsriesen, aber äh das,
die sind jetzt auch, sagen wir mal, nicht unbedingt jetzt unmittelbar äh ich meine jetzt versuchen sie ganz opportunistisch erstmal so ein bisschen auf Marketingebene da äh was für sich zu gewinnen. Gut, meinetwegen, ja, langfristig werden sie aber dieselben Fragen gestellt bekommen,
die ganze Diskussion von den USA wegdrehen und man wird sagen ja OK jetzt haben wir unsere Daten bei euch wie sieht's denn bei euch aus?
Macht ihr das gleiche Spiel oder oder was? Dann können wir uns auch gleich wieder was äh eigenes einfallen lassen,
Na ja, also da könnte man jetzt noch ewig drüber reden und äh drüber philosophieren auch, ob ob es technische Lösungsansätze gibt. Wenn du mich fragst.
Ich halte das für möglich, schlicht und ergreifend, weil das ganze Internet ist ein technischer Lösungsansatz,
Das ist ja nicht so, dass das vom Himmel gefallen wäre, sondern auch das Internet hat sich in der aktuellen Struktur einfach so entwickelt, als Lösung für
die Probleme, die man zuerst mal gesehen hat. Kommunikationsprobleme
schnelle Zugänglichkeit von äh Daten und Informationen, äh die Kollaboration
Menschen und so weiter. Und da hat sich dann immer wieder eine Lösung gefunden und viel ist auch, sagen wir mal, schon fertig gelöst und jetzt stellen wir einfach fest, es gibt einfach ein ganz anderes grundsätzliches Problem. Und warum sollte das auf einmal nicht,
angegangen werden können und genauso auch zu interessanten Folgen kommen. Ich meine, so Sachen wie bitterend, die so aus dem Nichts kam,
und dann auf einmal äh sechzig Prozent des Internet-Traffics stellen. Ja, und die auch sagen wir, also gerade bitter und halte ich so für so eine oder Dinge.
Mit das Coolste, ja.
Dinge wie Bit Toren, ja? Halte ich gerade für ganz heiße Eisen. Da äh tut sich eine Menge. Ja, so verschlüsselt da, voll verschlüsselter, verteilter Traffic und so.
Klar, derzeit ist das alles noch nicht da, es ist alles nicht greifbar und deswegen kann man das auch schnell für ja, das sind ja alles nur Hirngespinste von irgendwelchen,
ten Hackern halten so, ja, aber dieses.
Die gleichen Hacker, die dir vor einem Jahr erzählt haben, die NSA hört alles ab.
Genau und die und die selben Hacker, die auch vor allem vor dreißig Jahren hier dieses ganze Netz mitgestaltet und gebaut haben. So und deswegen ist es sehr vermessen ähm so eine Rolle äh einzunehmen und äh ich
halte da das Rennen für mindestens ähm um entscheidbar, ne. Letztlich muss man sich jetzt auch nicht das Ziel setzen mit ja
Morgen kommt Tool X und dann laden wir das alle runter und dann gibt es keine Überwachung mehr.
Ja, so ein bisschen ist, glaube ich, so ein bisschen wie auch so mit äh den Schulden dieses Staates, ja? Die Bundesregierung arbeitet seit vielen Jahren daraufhin, woraufhin nicht schuldenfrei zu sein, sondern.
Neuverschuldung zu deckeln.
Den Anstieg, den Anstieg der Neuverschuldung sozusagen zu bremsen. Und in gewisser Hinsicht fände ich
schon das Ausbremsen des Anstiegs der äh Massenüberwachung äh das würde ich ja schon mal für einen Erfolg halten.
Das ist eine sehr schöne Forderung. Die Neuüberwachung. Wir fordern eine Deckelung der Neuüberwachung.
Genau. Wir müssen den Anstieg der neuen Massenneuüberwachung äh müssen wir einfach auf null bringen.
So machen wir das. Bis dahin jedoch.
Unterliegen wir, ach ja, äh wir kommen zum Snowden Teil, Snowden, ne, dass er ein einschneidende äh einschneidendes einschneidende.
Was war das überhaupt? Das war der der Urknall des des deutschen Fernsehens, ja? Äh,
Snowden-Interview. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das, also das sind so die ARD wird man jetzt auch in ein Prä- und post äh snoaden live Intervi.
Ja
Was ist denn deine Theorie dazu, warum die das äh in um dreiundzwanzig Uhr gesendet haben?
Abgesehen davon, dass ich mich von so aussende Uhrzeiten, Konzepten ohnehin.
Ja gut, das ist aber.
Habe, ähm ja, ist eine gute Frage. Weiß nicht, äh wie ist denn das überhaupt genau gelaufen? Ich habe das auch alles so am Rande mitbekommen. Äh es es wurde also ein Interview geführt mit Herrn Snoten. Sechs Stunden lang.
Halbe Stunde davon kam im Fernsehen.
Haben sie dann zusammengeschnippelt und in einer deutsch übersetzten Variante ins Fernsehen gebracht. Das lief um dreiundzwanzig Uhr nach den Tagesthemen und die Tagesthemen liefen nach der Debatte über dieses Interview.
Ja, ja. Ja.
Stimmt das? Mit Herrn Jauch, ja, auch sehr erfahren und immer wieder sehr äh zielsicher bei politischen Diskussionen. Nord,
Also da hat irgendjemand den den ähm das Fernsehprogramm umgedreht.
Und da haben sie dann, ich habe die Jahressendung, ich kann ja auch nicht gucken, also der kriegt zu viel. Also das, das tue ich mir nicht an, da kriege ich wirklich Wutausbrüche.
Überfordert mich auch.
Sind schon irgendwie das und dabei hatten sie dann jetzt ja eh die Marina Weißfand, die ich in kurzer Forder, die ist dann kurz nachdem ich sie da die ihr da die Frage gestellt habt, ist sie dann zum Jauch gegangen. Ähm.
Amduktus jetzt auch schon erkannt, dass sie schon geübt hat.
Ja das kann gut sein, ja. Natürlich, ich meine wenn man sie halt bittet, in äh kurz eine Stellung zu nehmen, dann ist da auch völlig okay.
Nee, ist vollkommen klar. Es war eine es war nur eine kleine Spitze. Äh das ist so ein manchmal, manchmal, manchmal muss man halt so ein, ein, ein Klagerichteten Mediensprech äh einfach an den Tag legen, auch wenn das nicht unbedingt immer überall passend ist.
Das kannst du durchaus auch mal vorkommen. Auf jeden Fall, genau dann haben sie die Marina weiß man dahin gesetzt mit dem ähm,
zum Bildreporter oder sowas ich dann auf Twitter,
wie dem auch sei. Was waren die die großen, die großen Andeutungen aus diesem Interview waren, glaube ich, dass er gesagt hat, ja ähm.
Könnte ja jetzt nichts vorwegnehmen, aber so Wirtschaftsspionage nicht zu betreiben mit diesem Apparat würde,
sich ja dann schon auch drüber wundern, wenn das so wäre, oder? Also das war, glaube ich, so sein Kommentar. Er hat jetzt nicht äh direkt gesagt, natürlich betreiben die USA Wirtschaftsspionage, aber er hat angedeutet, dass da ähm.
Dass man sich doch darüber wundern würde, wenn man's nicht so sieht.
Wenn das nicht so wäre, ne? Aber sonst erinnere ich mich jetzt auch nicht an irgendwas Großes. Was allerdings schon groß war diese Woche, war dann eben.
NSA offensichtlich auch die Klimakonferenz in Kopenhagen angegriffen hat. Und das ist natürlich schon eine äh also würde mich jetzt auch, also man wundert sich ja sowieso nicht mehr, aber ähm.
Nö. Aber ähm nur, dass es rauskommt.
Das ist schon übel. Bei der war ich auch übrigens damals, da sind wir nach Kopenhagen gefahren zur Klimakonferenz. Also nicht als Teilnehmer, sondern als.
Beobachter. Demonstrant. Mhm.
Ja genau unabhängige Beobachter, genau. Gegen Christiania, aber da äh,
Ja ja klar, äh das war gut. Das war das war eigentlich eine schöne Zeit. Da habe ich jetzt gerade dran gedacht. Ähm,
Da haben sie auch äh abgehört und diese Klimakonferenzen sind ja immer von diesen Zähnen Verhandlungen geprägt. Ich glaube an diese von dieser Klimakonferenz, da war dann das große Thema China, ne,
dass dann die USA irgendwie versucht haben, China den schwarzen Peter zuzuschieben.
Ne, ist halt immer so dieses Spiel zwischen USA und China, so nach dem Motto, ja, wir werden ja im Prinzip für äh alle möglichen Zugeständnisse bereit, aber die Chinesen müssen sich ja auch bewegen und wenn die sich nicht bewegen, dann bewegen wir uns halt auch nicht.
Also das schöne Beispiel ist, ich meine, wenn sie wirklich ich meine, diese Form der Kontrolle über internationale Politik zu haben, ja, wenn du weißt.
Wie die ähm.
Wie die Verhandlungsposition des äh des des Anderen ist. Äh das ist schon natürlich sehr beängstigend. Wobei ja ohnehin,
äh grob so die so will es die Legende, ich hab jetzt noch nie als Chefunterhändler fürn fürn äh,
schon gesagt für einen Konzern, für einen für einen Staat irgendwo an so einer Konferenz teilgenommen. Aber dass man da durchaus sich der Situation dann auch bewusst ist und das dann auch gerne mal,
etwas, wo man möchte, dass der andere das weiß, dann eben laut auf dem Flur besprochen wird oder so, weil man davon aus oder weil man grundsätzlich eigentlich davon ausgeht und,
Damit spielt, dass da natürlich auch die Dienste der einzelnen Länder anwesend sind und versuchen irgendwie die die Verhandlungen durch ihr Wissen äh zu bereichern. Weiß ich nicht, ob das so ist, aber die ähm.
Die Legende gibt's schon länger. Das ist das ist so, dass sowas stattfinden. Und dass eben auch die einzelnen Teilnehmer sich dessen bewusst sind.
Und das andere war dann diese die Apps die NSA hängt in den Apps.
Bevor bevor wir zu äh Angry Birds kommen. Ich ich finde jetzt diese Meldung insofern sehr interessant, als das ja immer dieses Thema geht.
Naja, sollen sie doch überwachen? Ich merke davon ja nichts,
davon nichts merke, dann betrifft mich das auch nicht. Ich glaube an dieser Stelle haben wir ein sehr schönes Beispiel dafür,
Ja, wie das sehr wohl was äh ähm bewirken kann, nämlich die Überflutung von äh Ufern auf der Welt, ja, der Anstieg der Meere, der einfach nicht vorangeht,
eine Gruppe äh ihre Position äh mit dem Wissen ausspielt wie alle anderen pokern
Das ist so ein bisschen so ein Schachspiel, wo du quasi alle äh Stellungsinterpretationen der Gegenseite äh,
mitgeteilt bekommst. Und neben der Einschätzung, was irgendwie nicht geht et cetera. Und das ist halt nun mal genau das, was man eben benötigt
um äh seine Position maximal durchsetzen zu können. Wie die Position der Amerikaner ist, wissen wir, die ist nicht unbedingt davongetragen, jetzt hier irgendwie den Planeten zu retten, sondern sie ist halt davon getragen, wirtschaftliche Vormachtstellung
zu retten. Das gilt sicherlich auch für viele andere Länder, genauso für Deutschland und China et cetera, aber wir wissen, dass oder man könnte jetzt zumindest davon ausgehen,
dass ja, wenn alle so ein bisschen mit Fragezeichen am Tisch sitzen und man sich dann doch sehr viel schneller äh einigen könnte. So oder so.
Das zeigt einfach äh das Problem wieder sehr schön. So und Angry Birds, na ja.
Na ja, okay, also dass du das dann jetzt auch nehmen äh.
Ist, ist einfach nur konsequent, oder?
Ja, also äh bei Rovio zeigte man sich überrascht. Ja, welch Wunder,
aber ist ja nicht so, dass diese Programme nicht auch äh solche Tracking-Dienstleister äh äh alle in Anspruch nehmen, also auch auf Game-Ebene gibt's mittlerweile genug.
Auswerter, ich weiß nicht, was da alles jetzt wirklich ausgewertet wird, aber was auch immer dort ausgewertet wird, wird,
eben dann auch mitgeschnorchelt. Da kann man mal davon sowieso mal unterstellen, dass vielleicht viele dieser äh Unternehmen,
die ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt alle besondere Riesen sind und besondere äh Festigkeit äh äh besitzen sehr wohl auch ähm Hintergrundgespräche äh führen von Zeit zu Zeit,
Und auch das ist natürlich etwas, wo man die Integrität äh seiner eigenen Produkte nochmal schön in Frage stellen kann, wo wir das mal aufgreifen hier mit was was können wir selber tun, ne?
Das auf jeden Fall. Ich ich bin mir wie immer, was also das äh das Gerät für mich ja zum.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob ich das jetzt gut oder schlecht finden soll. Die technischen Details fehlen wie immer. Also offensichtlich hat AdWords auch immer nur,
PowerPoint-Folien rausgetragen oder was? Äh,
die technischen Details fehlen wie immer. Und das ist natürlich dann einerseits ganz schön, weil man dann irgendwie äh sich im im,
Grüppchen hinsetzen kann und sagt, was meinst du, wo haben die das gemacht? Haben sie tatsächlich Rovio den Angry Birds äh Betreiber da irgendwie aufgemacht? Oder ähm,
wie gesagt, ich spiele keine Angry Birds, aber könnte man jetzt mal gucken, es ist durchaus möglich, dass weil es ja nur ein Spiel ist,
gesamte Angry wird's halt nicht verschlüsselt mit seinem Heimserverrät und die einfach da, weil sie eh auf dem Kabel sitzen, wo sie alles ab äh schnorcheln, dann das direkt auch noch mit äh in ihrem Netz hatten,
weiß ich gar nicht genau und ähm in diesem Fall ähm hat's mich jetzt auch nicht so sehr interessiert, dass ich dem weiter auf den Grund gegangen bin.
Naja, schön fand ich auf jeden Fall diese äh kleine Grafik bei äh Reise DE, das NSE-Logo mit diesem Angry Birds weiße Adler, Weißkopfadler.
Das äh muss natürlich rein, das äh live hat das gemacht, sehr schön hat er das gemacht. Oder S oder sie.
Sehr schön. Gut.
Aber äh so diese diese ne, diese diese Apps und so, also diese Smartphones, die entwickeln sich ja schon ähm immer mehr zu sage ich mal dem,
Problem ach so, live hat er's gar nicht gemacht. Na ja, ähm,
Die entwickeln sich ja schon immer mehr zu dem Problem, dass sie dass den Menschen jetzt irgendwie klar wird, okay, das einzige Ding, was sich da
der wirkliche Spion ist, der in meiner Hosentasche, ne, dieses kleine
Gerät, was äh von dem ein Mobilfunknetz sowieso immer weiß, äh wo es sich gerade aufhält und von dem
irgendwie die Geheimdienste wissen, dass es mir gehört und dass außerdem der Kamera ein Mikrofon unten Internetanschluss hat und ein Bluetooth und was nicht alles.
Das äh entwickelt sich da echt zu einem äh zu einem Problemchen. So ja auch.
Elegante Überleitung in der Ukraine.
Oh ja
Genau, ja, die Ukraine, äh wir erinnern uns, es ist äh gerade schwer in einem Schockzustand, kann man sagen. Äh Revolutions ähm Momente.
So richtig ja da geht's richtig rund und man weiß nicht so richtig, was da äh eigentlich jetzt als nächstes so passieren wird, aber es gibt ganz offensichtlich da eine klare Konfrontation zwischen Leuten, die dagegen sind und dem Staat,
und dieser äh Staat nutzt offensichtlich alle Register der Macht äh von Schläger äh Trupps, über ähm natürlich alle rechtlichen ähm Mittel und neue Gesetze und natürlich auch die in der Telekommunikation möglichen Sachen. Und so war es, dass
diesem Maidan Platz, äh die äh alle Anwesenden, die ein Mobilfunktelefon dabei hatten, was sicherlich,
ganze Menge waren. Äh auf einmal eine SMS bekamen, in der, jetzt weiß ich gar nicht mehr ganz genau, was der Original äh Text war.
Wenn ich richtig täusche, ist die Übersetzung, sie wurden registriert als der Teilnehmer einer Demonstration oder einer bösartigen. Ich schaue nochmal ganz kurz, ich ich.
Ja und so äh man sollte sich doch bisschen bewusst sein, dass man jetzt hier äh unter Überwachung äh stehen würde.
Genau.
Also sie werden registriert als Teilnehmer einer Massenstörung. Das ist schon äh.
Schon scharf. Ja, ist gar kein Problem für Mobilfunknetz. Wie gesagt, das weiß sowieso, wo du gerade bist. Es muss es ja wissen. Es will ja dein Telefon klingeln lassen, wenn du ähm angerufen wirst.
Also grob weiß es das, ähm kann es auch natürlich genauer herausfinden und da haben sie offensichtlich einfach mal was was.
Man eben macht, so gesagt, okay, alle Telefon, die jetzt grade in diesem Bereich sind, also sich in dieser in dem Bereich dieser Zellen hier aufhalten, das wird ja wahrscheinlich noch nicht mal ein so großer,
Bereich sein,
den schicken wir einfach mal eine SMS, ist ohne Zweifel möglich. In dem Ausmaß, also diese Einschüchterung, die da stattgefunden hat, ist natürlich irre und hat vor ein paar Jahren schon im Iran stattgefunden, wenn ich mich,
falsch erinnere. Ja, also eines der Länder mit I und A und Irak, was nicht. Also,
Iran. Ich meine, das es der Iran war oder ein eine andere äh also ein anderes der Länder, die ähm.
Da erinnere ich mich auf jeden Fall dran. Äh vielleicht war's auch ein.
Keine große Überraschung, aber war einfach mal wieder so ein schöner Moment und ich glaube, solche Sachen, die,
feuern dann auch eher zurück. Also man ukrainische Regierung scheint sich ja einiges einfallen gelassen zu haben,
und die Leute so richtig auf die Palme zu bringen.
Die haben ja vor allem äh ist jetzt auch heute, dass man wirklich fürchterliche Bilder von diesem Menschen in der gefoltert wurde. Also äh meine Güte, also.
Na ja, die haben da halt so Präsident, den Präsidenten unterstellte.
Garden, die wo diese Bergi äh irgendwie kein,
keine Angst haben, komplett über die Stränge zu schlagen und die Leute irgendwie maximal zu erniedrigen und zu demütigen. Nur das geht halt irgendwie in in der Mediengesellschaft dann auch so ein bisschen nach hinten los.
Das läuft ja auch alles im Fernsehen, also es ist Fernsehen scheinen sie jetzt nicht in dem Maße äh unter Kontrolle zu haben, dass das jetzt so Putinstyle äh komplett ausgeblendet wird,
und das weiß ich nicht, könnte am Ende die Ukraine auch nochmal retten, auch wenn es derzeit echt überhaupt nicht zu sagen ist, wie's da äh ausgehen wird.
Na gut, das überlassen wir mal anderen Podcast. Die Interpretation der Ereignisse,
Kommen wir auf ein äh anderes Problem, was wir schon vor einiger Zeit hätten äh ansprechen können, aber durch so viele andere Themen wurde das irgendwie so ein bisschen überlagert und ich hab's auch nur so mit einem Auge verfolgt.
Das ist das ist jetzt ein Thema, das war Netzpolitik,
vor drei Jahren oder so. Da haben wir uns schön mit dem Urheberrecht auseinandersetzen können, ne? Da konnte das, da konnten wir noch in unseren äh Berlin Mitte Cafes
intellektuell daherschwafeln über eine neue Zukunft ohne dass es um Menschenleben oder sonst was geht. Damals mit Urheberrecht auseinandergesetzt.
Es waren noch Zeiten.
Also.
Schön war's.
Während wir, während wir.
Ich diese Diskussion nicht so richtig vermisse, um ehrlich zu sein.
Urheberrechtsdiskussion, ach ja.
Furchtbar. Ja, ja, ja. Worüber müssen wir jetzt reden? Also äh es gibt da zweierlei ähm.
Dieses DRM in HTML fünf. Ich meine, mich erinnern zu können, dass wir das schon mal irgendwie grob in einer Sendung äh hier behandelt haben.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, aber wir erklären's einfach noch mal,
Und zwar geht es darum, dass in den in den neuen HTML fünf Standard, der ja schon von einigen benutzt wird, aber noch nicht abgeschlossen ist,
aufgenommen werden soll, eine Funktion zum verschlüsselten oder,
Zum übertragen eines Schlüssels den der Browser benötigt, um das Material, was ihm zugesendet wird, wieder zu entschlüsseln.
So ist das erstmal äh dort spezifiziert. Da geht's nicht spezifisch darum, dass man da jetzt unbedingt Digital Rights Management drüber machen möchte.
Aber überlegen wir uns kurz, wofür das sinnvoll sein könnte. Also der Browser spricht sowieso entweder verschlüsselt oder unverschlüsselt mit dem Zielserver,
Wir wollen hoffen, dass sich das in Zukunft dazu ändert, dass mehr SSL genutzt wird und auch richtig, sodass der äh Browser mit dem Zielserver vollständig verschlüsselt spricht,
Es gibt also keine eigentlich keinen Grund, überhaupt Verschlüsselung in das Protokoll oder in in das,
in das in die HTML zu bringen, weil das ja etwas ist, was der Browser über die entweder unverschlüsselte oder verschlüsselte Verbindung von seinem Server bekommt,
dann zu interpretieren hat. Da heißt, das heißt, auf der, auf diesem hat Verschlüsselung eigentlich nichts mehr verloren,
Wenn, dann würde man sie weiter darunter anbringen. Also es bringt keinen, es ist das falsche Layout. Äh man ist auf dem falschen Layer, wenn man sagt, okay, wir bringen jetzt wir machen die Verschlüsselung in HTML fünf rein.
Alter, du bist ja voll aufm falschen Leer.
Ja, deshalb war wirklich mal das falsche Layer oder nicht? Du bist doch der, du argumentierst immer über die. Ich habe die OSI Lea bis heute nicht auswendig gelernt.
Was?
Weil sie ja werden sie nun Zeuge, wie Tim Pritlaff, die sie.
Wie immer.
Nee, machen wir, komm. Kleiner Exkurs, ja sicher, ich weiß nur.
Überhaupt gar keine Rolle. Da spielt doch jetzt echt keine Rolle.
Möchtest du nicht einmal kurz die, ich finde, ich finde das echt schön, wenn du für die Hörer die sieben Layer erklären würdest. Aber wir können's auch müssen wir wissen. Ich fänd's super.
Ich ich erkläre gerne diese sieben Ursula, wenn sie eine Rolle spielen würden hier. Hier geht's jetzt einfach mal um was anderes. Also,
Die Sache ist für mich auch noch sehr verworren und ehrlich gesagt, ich verstehe nicht so richtig, was da eigentlich gerade passiert.
Also was sie was sie bauen ist, ganz kurz noch, um das abzuschließen. Ein sie wollen in HTML standardisieren, dass ein Objekt ankommt, verschlüsselt von diesem Server ausgeliefert wird und sich der Browser an einer anderen Stelle den Schlüssel dafür holt.
Für meinen Geschmack ist es mir jetzt ein zu technischer Einstieg. Ich werde jetzt mal äh anders aufziehen. Also auf einem, also es gibt dieses W3C.
C, sehr bekannt, hat lange, lange Zeit quasi die Standards entwickelt, die äh,
ausmachen, äh gegründet äh und auch immer noch angeführt von Tim Burners Lee, der äh gelobt sein seine hellen Tage. Äh Anfang der neunziger Jahre auf seiner Nextwork-Station
das World Wide Web erfunden hat, das Prinzip erfunden hat und den ersten Browser namens World Wide Web äh entwickelt hat,
sowas ging halt damals auf dem äh Next, da konnte ein Mann noch einen Webbrowser programmieren,
und äh insofern hat er äh viele äh große äh Verdienste äh sozusagen zusammengetragen und da wurde ja auch gebührend
gefeiert, als er dann bei der Eröffnungs- oder Abschlussveranstaltung, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau, für den Olympischen Spielen in London ja sogar aufs Feld gebeten wurde und da so ein bisschen wie so ein wie
der Erfinder des Webs und solche Menschen gibt es auch ah ja so und dann doch wieder die anderen Superstars,
Na ja, ähm ich muss sagen, ich fand den Typen schon immer so ein bisschen merkwürdig, weil der ist halt auch so ein,
so ein akademischer Nerd, der sich irgendwie komplett wegschließt. Der hat vor ein paar Jahren dann das erste Mal seinen Twitter-Account in Betrieb genommen und ich glaube, seitdem irgendwie drei oder vier oder fünf Tweets abgesetzt,
gucken, ob mittlerweile was.
Das denn für einer? Deswegen findest du den komisch?
Dass er so wenig getwittert hat.
Na ja, ey, also ich meine, wenn du Web erfunden hast, dann brauchst du wohl keinen Twitter-Account.
Also, nö, nee, ich meine, er könnte auch ganz konsequent einfach keinen haben. Aber ich meine, wenn er einen hat.
Vielleicht ist das ja gar nicht seiner.
Macht er denn äh dann damit, ne? Also auch.
Vielleicht hat er sich das nachher anders überlegt, dass er sagt, nee, ich gehe jetzt lieber zu oder so.
Ja, okay.
Du, ich gucke jetzt nochmal nach, wie, auf wie viel Tweets er äh mittlerweile gebracht hat. Oh, ah, oh, ich muss mich zurücknehmen. Also, er hat dann tatsächlich schon vierhundertfünfzig äh Tweets zusammengetragen.
Aha. Aha. Okay, das ist natürlich für dich jetzt keine Anzahl, aber.
Nee.
Okay, also Tim Börnerslee wird dahin gekarrt und ist ein komischer Kautz, weil er irgendwie nicht genug twittert.
Na ja, ich will ihnen jetzt auch nicht schlecht machen. Das ist nur so, äh er führt das an,
Jetzt ist die W drei C aber jetzt auch nicht unbedingt die die mega erfolgreiche äh äh Organisation, als man sie auch hinstellen äh könnte, wenn man sich mal anschaut, wie viel Erfolg sie mit ihren HTML-Vorstößen äh hatten in den letzten Jahren,
weil sie sind eigentlich gescheitert an sich selbst, ja? Ihre Vision war
einerseits demantisches Web und die Zukunft ist XML und XHTML und haben dann irgendwie XHTM mit eins und äh eins eins und waren auch schon an Version zwei am Arbeiten, als die Leute irgendwie immer noch äh HTML vier,
real zum Einsatz gebracht haben. Und irgendwie wollte dieses keiner haben. Und wenn man sich das mal genau anschaut,
und das habe ich gemacht. Da weiß man auch warum. Dass nichts werden konnte. Und so wurde es auch nichts und dann gab's eben diesen Vorstoß HTML fünf,
Und lange, lange Zeit gab's vor allem diese andere Gruppe, diese Wort WG. Ähm,
die im Wesentlichen diesen Standard hervorgebracht hat. Das ist nämlich das, was mich jetzt sowieso so ein bisschen wundert an dieser ganzen Sache. Wie drei C ist eigentlich gar nicht so der Geburtsort von HTML fünf
ja? Ist die jetzt auf einmal irgendwie da, äh das Heft in die Hand nehmen, da habe ich irgendwas nicht mitbekommen. Vielleicht kann uns einer der Hörer auch da ein wenig äh aufklären. Und jetzt geschehen wundersame Dinge. Unter anderem tritt jetzt die
MPA, dem W3C bei.
Genau, also so die muss Hardcore Copyright äh,
Verfolger ja vom vom Herrn,
Und vor allem gibt es eben das von dir jetzt eingangs schon erwähnte diesen Plan einen Standard zu machen, einen FC, äh ein W drei C Standard, Entschuldigung.
Nee, sogar das in äh HTML fünf Punkt eins mit zu integrieren, dass das das gibt's einfach. Du bist nicht HTML fünf eins Compliant, wenn du nicht dieses auch hast.
Na ja, diese Compliance gibt's so bei HTML fünf in dem Sinne nicht mehr, weil der Standard ist eigentlich so ein permanentes Living äh document und es gibt da nicht so einen Stempel, du hast jetzt die
oder so, sondern man hat jetzt,
dass diese Weiterentwicklung ein ein ständiger Fluss ist und dieses jetzt haben wir diese Version und jetzt machen wir die nächste Version und die muss dann auch noch implementieren. Das ist jetzt alles sehr viel äh modularisierter.
Nur es gibt zu Recht keinen Widerstand dagegen, jetzt eine äh eine eine eine Komponente zu definieren, einen Standard zu definieren, der im Prinzip,
Open-Source verhindert. Oder.
Nicht so ohne Weiteres realisieren ließe, weil wir hier von äh reden, die ja dann quasi äh in Brausan aktiv werden sollen, um diesen in Content abzuspielen.
Ah, das ist natürlich ja okay, ja, das stimmt.
Ja, weil wenn's irgendwie Open Saurs wäre, dann könntest du ja da deinen Key nehmen und das äh ich meine, wovon wovon reden wir? Wir reden hier von dem
von DVDs
ja? Man hat da so einen Schlüssel äh in diesen Geräten und dann legt man da die diese DVD ein und dann kann man das abspielen, aber man kann sie nicht so ohne Weiteres kopieren. Dann kam die John, hat gesagt, hier ist der Key
äh
und deswegen kann man heutzutage problemlos DVDs rippen, weil er einfach in the wild ist und der ist verbrannt und damit ist die ganze Verschlüsselung einfach dahin. So, wäre ja schön, wenn man diesen äh Schlüssel immer wieder neu machen kann
Systeme wie äh Apple TV zum Beispiel ja und diese ganzen anderen Boxen, die haben halt äh im Prinzip das ganze
mit drin oder kommuniziere mit Netflix auf eine andere Art und Weise,
Netflix ist auch, sagen wir mal so ein Unternehmen, was hier nicht so bekannt ist, aber in den USA eine richtig große Rolle spielt, das ist da der Ort, wo,
Fernsehen äh über Internet sich im Prinzip am besten äh entwickelt. Die haben halt viele Deals, äh können halt äh Filme äh günstig,
anbieten, die hatten auch früher so eine DVD-Flatrate, wo man so einen festen Betrag bezahlt hat und dann konnte man sich irgendwie so
mehrere DVDs pro Monat irgendwie immer zuschicken lassen. Also es war quasi so ein Versenden Versenderverleiher, ja?
Ähm und die sind aber jetzt eben auf ja voll eigentlich auf dem digitalen Marsch. Und jetzt ist quasi so die Ankündigung na ja,
Wir wollen jetzt mal äh das Ganze auch in Webbrowsern haben, weil sonst brauchen wir ja immer diese komischen Implinces und unser Markt wäre ja viel größer,
im Prinzip auf jedem Computer geht, aber da haben wir ja wieder dieses Problem mit dem offenen Web und wenn man da irgendwie unser DRM machen wollen, dann lässt sich das ja so nicht durchsetzen
Wäre ja toll, wenn's da einen Standard äh für gäbe, der irgendwie mal genau definiert, wie das alles funktioniert. Und wäre ja toll, wenn wir mal äh Anbieter hätten, die sagen wir mal solchen
Interessen durchaus positiv gegenüber stehen. Ja, wir würden uns denn da zum Beispiel einfallen, ja äh da wäre ja zum Beispiel mal,
Apple a hoppala, die haben ja auch einen Browser so, ja, dann haben wir da noch äh Google, ach die haben auch einen Browser.
Und das ist so quasi so ein bisschen so diese Verschwörung. Die sich da gerade äh abspielt. Das ist alles ein bisschen merkwürdig. Korry Doktor Rau geht schon auf ein Zahnfleisch,
Ja, der ist so richtig äh äh so richtig down, äh wie hieß nochmal gleich sein Block? Äh Eintrag.
Der ist aber länger her, oder?
Nein, der ist vom neunten, ja, ist vom neunten Januar, also was heißt länger her? Das ist jetzt irgendwie drei Wochen alt, wo er irgendwie äh meinte, äh in seinem Blogsling,
und äh so.
Sagt.
Ja, so, also er befürchtet hier äh schlicht, dass,
das einfach jetzt das Ende des offenen Webs ist. Und dafür äh na ja,
ist, sagen wir mal, der Aufstand da noch relativ gering. Und ich frage mich halt auch ernsthaft, was was hat äh so eine Technologie äh da äh zu suchen, ja.
Das wollte ich ja gerade ähm meinen Layer Ansatz sagen, aber du wolltest ja nicht.
Wo sie leer.
Ne, es gehört halt also das Ding ist, es gehört da einfach nicht hin
So, also das es gehört nicht in HTML rein. Also sie wollen, was sie äh standardisieren wollen, ist eben dieser AP Zugriff und da wird halt
also dass man über eine API noch etwas anderes dazu braucht, um dieses Video zu sehen und diese API ist natürlich dann die,
Ende, was dir sagt, ob du den Film jetzt sehen darfst oder nicht.
Und wenn dieser, wenn das verbunden ist mit einem closed Force Teil in deinem Browser, dann kannst du den Film eben nicht speichern.
Ja, also
Das ist alles noch sehr verwirrend und ähm ich wundere mich so ein bisschen, dass das noch nicht mehr auf der Agenda ist, also bei Korry Doktor ist es offensichtlich auf der Agenda Bollenbeugen schreibt natürlich dann entsprechend viel dazu. Die IFS hat das Thema wohl schon aufgenommen, aber wir noch nicht so richtig.
Ich weiß nicht, äh also ich ich meine, wir haben Flash-Player überlebt.
Haben wir, also mich nervt das Ding immer noch jeden Tag.
Ich habe den einfach nicht. Ja, also.
Ja, ich auch nicht, aber dann hast du halt häufig das Problem, dass du da mal so an relevante Quellen grade mal nicht rankommst. So schlimm das ist.
Ja, aber also ich, ja, also Flash, ich ich finde, wir haben na ja, okay, wir haben ihn deshalb überlebt, weil wir dachten, weil wir gemerkt haben, okay, wir können jetzt alles in HTML fünf machen. Offensichtlich auch tatsächlich alles, ja.
Na ja, im Prinzip ist genau dieses Aussperren von,
Flash, ja, was nämlich derzeit quasi der Bit Bucket ist, wo äh genau das eben möglich ist, ja. Das ist ja so die Closed Box des Internets. Und dadurch, dass Flash aber jetzt von Apple äh so ein wenig ähm getötet wurde, ja und gesagt hat, wir wollen hier Standards haben,
Ja, mir ist auch die Rolle von Apple an der Stelle äh irgendwie noch nicht so richtig klar. Also ähm,
Habe da jetzt noch keine konkrete Äußerungen dazu äh gesehen,
aber offensichtlich geht das hier alles voran. Naja gut, wir haben's jetzt erstmal erwähnt und werden das äh später nochmal aufgreifen,
Gibt ja noch weitere äh Bewegungen rund um das Spaßthema Urheberrecht.
Ja, eine eine sehr äh sehr interessante Meldung ähm ist eigentlich nur eine Randmeldung. Die Urheberrechtsabgabe da gab's jetzt einen Kompromiss zwischen dem deutschen Branchenverband Bitcom
und den Verwertern, äh die sich die Verwerter haben verlangt, dass äh also wir wissen, die kriegen ja, glaube ich,
Rohlinge für USB-Sticks kriegen sie ja schon irgendwelche Urheberrechtsabgaben, weil diese Dinge ja offensichtlich zum Verletzen des Urheberrechtes genutzt werden.
Laufend. Nur machst das mit deinen USB-Sticks nicht auch?
Und ähm klar, urheberrecht nur über USB-Sticks.
Ja. Damit ich zeigen, was denen richtig.
Und weil du weil du sie dann natürlich konkret also konsequent zu Ende argumentiert, der Computer, jeder Computer ja quasi eine Urheberrechtsverletzung ist,
Ja, ist ja eine Druckerpresse. Ist ja direkt eine Urheberrechtsverletzung, wenn sich jemand sowas kauft.
Ja, das ist quasi eine Waffe. Eine urheberrechtsbekämpfungswaffe.
Seit zweitausendelf streiten, ja, sind ja offensichtlich in Verhandlungen oder sogar noch länger. Auf jeden Fall haben sie jetzt rückwirkend von zweitausendelf bis,
zweitausendsechzehn einen Kompromiss gefunden und das heißt, auf Desktop-PCs und Notebooks,
werden jetzt dreizehn Euro neunzig pro Gerät fällig.
Computer, dreizehn Euro neunzig, gehen an die Verwerter, die ja auch schon irgendwie immer Geld bekommen haben, wenn du dir einen CD-Brenner gekauft hast, die Geld bekommen haben, wenn du einen CD Rohling gekauft hast. Ähm,
Und ich meine mit den USB-Sticks, das hatten wir hier vor vor einigen Sendungen auch schon, dass da die Abgabe auf die USB-Sticks erhöht wurde.
Das ist natürlich schon interessant, interessanter Erfolg,
wenn du das schaffst, als als als Urheberrechtsverwerter, nicht nur den HTML äh Standard zu,
zu unterwandern und in deinem Sinne zu beeinflussen, sondern auch tatsächlich die Firmen, die Computer verkaufen, dazu zu bringen,
Prinzip für dich in zu machen. Für dich Geld einzusammeln und äh und dir zu überweisen.
Das ist jetzt einfach nur die, die Generalisierung auf den Gesamtcomputer, äh während das ja bisher nur bei bei iPods und so weiter halt, ob's ja diese Zahlung zum Beispiel auch schon, ja, also auch,
ganzen Music-Player. Äh in gewisser Hinsicht sogar noch weiß ich nicht, also da da komme ich mental noch mit, ja.
Noch mit, ja, da.
Genau, aber äh so. Und ich meine, ich frage mich halt bei solchen Urheberrechtsabgaben immer, okay,
ja? Kriegen wir dafür dann alles kostenlos oder was? Äh machen wir jetzt irgendwie alles äh auf Umlage? Gibt's irgendein Fair Yous? Also ich meine WhatsApp, was, was, was, was, was ist jetzt sozusagen äh was hat man davon, dass man denen jetzt noch Geld gibt
ohne irgendwie eine konkrete Dienstleistung äh in Anspruch zu nehmen. Das ist äh ja, es ist
auch wieder so ein Verteilungsschlüssel, der genauso fragwürdig ist, wie man das bei der GEMA äh auch immer schon für fragwürdig gehalten hat.
Man bezeichnet ein gesetzlich so ein gesetzlich verordneten Zuschlag auf den Preis bestimmter technischer Geräte mit urheberrechtlich geschützte Waren und Güter entweder vervielfältigt oder genutzt werden können,
und es ist der Paragraph vierundfünfzig Urheberrechtsschutzgesetz.
Der bezeichnet die Vergütungspflicht. Ist nach Art eines Wert Werkes zu erwarten, dass es nach Paragraph dreiundfünfzig Absatz eins bis drei vervielfältigt wird.
So hat der Urheber des Werkes,
gegen den Hersteller von Geräten und von Speichermedien, deren Typ allein oder in Verbindung mit anderen Geräten, Speichermedien oder Zubehör zur Vorname solcher Vervielfältigung benutzt wird,
Anspruch auf Zahlung einer angemessenen Vergütung,
der nach Absatz der Anspruch nach Absatz eins entfällt, soweit nach den Umständen erwartet werden kann, dass die Geräte oder Speichermedien im Geltungsbereich dieses Gesetzes nicht zur Vervielfältigung benutzt werden.
Das ist Gesetz in Deutschland.
Vervielfältigung, ja.
Also nur wenn erwartet werden kann, dass die Geräte oder Speichermedien nicht dazu genutzt werden, zu Vervielfältigung, dann entfällt dieser Anspruch und dann mit dieser dann ist das.
Insofern sehr lustig ist, als dass hier ein iPod nun wirklich überhaupt nicht zur Vervielfältigung taucht.
Ja, aber das gilt ja auch für äh nee, das stimmt. Okay.
Also ich meine, man könnte ja argumentieren, dass er sozusagen der Ort ist, in den hinein vervielfältigt wird.
Und zwar vom Computer aus und deswegen müssen wir jetzt dreizehn neunzig dafür.
Ja, also auf beiden Seiten sozusagen. Ja, also sowohl beim Senden, als auch beim Empfangen muss äh Gebühr bezahlt.
Es ist also es ist ein wirklich sehr, sehr skurriles Gesetz. Man.
Ja, das ist so wie Telefonate in USA, wo du dann als bei deinem Mobilfunk Provider auch noch dafür bezahlst, dass dich Leute anrufen.
Ja, das ist aber ein anderes Bezahlmodell. Ich meine, dafür äh zahlt die Leute ja nicht, wenn sie dich anrufen. Ach so, nee, stimmt, wenn sie vom Mobiltelefon aus anrufen schon, aber äh.
Das glaube ich gar nicht so. Also ich glaube, da wird auch teilweise doppelt bezahlt.
Na klar, wenn du Mobilfunk zum Mobilfunk wärst, dann sogar doppelt bezahlt, ja. Ist doch schön, ist doch super. So floriert der Markt, lieber Tim. Alles andere.
Ja, man muss sich einfach nur Stellen ausdenken, genau.
Wundern, wenn morgen, ne, hier Mindestlohn.
Das aber böser Kommunismus. Da bleiben wir lieber bei unserer kapitalistischen Grundwirtshorn, da wird alles gut.
Genau da haben wir Glück
Haben wir Glück. Aber so irre, so eine Urheberrechtsabgabe. Also ist geltendes Recht. Was soll man dazu noch sagen? Das Spannende ist ja, der Bitcom musste sich ja, der Bitcoin hat ja gar keinen Bock dadrauf. Die haben ja sogar dann der,
Bernd Roleder hat ja dann sogar noch gesagt, wir sehen das äh äh überhaupt nicht ein hier
aber ähm sind froh, dass wir den Preis irgendwie niedrig halten konnten, denn das Gesetz ist nunmal so und wenn sie äh wenn der Bitcoin da jetzt irgendwie großartig von
geklagt hätte oder so, das hätten sie verloren. Den Gesetzestext haben wir ja gerade verlesen.
Zwanzig Prozent Rabatt, ne, immerhin.
Genau, ach ja, super gut, dass das da sagt, der Bitcom hat nämlich für für Mitglieder seines Verbandes zwanzig Prozent Rabatt auf die Tarife ausgehandelt. Was ist das denn bitte für eine Nummer?
Was ist es wenn wenn du bei uns mitmachst? Kriegst du korrekte Preis?
Und fürs zum Sommerfest eingeladen.
Bestimmt mit der Kanzlerin wahrscheinlich.
Letztes Mal war der Philipp Rößler, glaube ich. Er ist vor zwei Jahren, ich war letztes Jahr nie.
Oh. Dann will ich aber fünfundzwanzig Prozent. Na ja gut, das kann jetzt nicht wieder passieren.
Aber das finde ich dann auch wieder nicht in Ordnung, aber okay, weil das ist ja eh, der Bitcom mit den Verwertern, wer weiß, also okay, komm. Nächstes Thema, auch ein spannendes Thema.
Nächstes Thema, auch ein spannendes Thema. Ja, ja, unsere äh ist ja gut, dass wir freie Medien haben, ja.
Investigativ Journalisten haben wir. Wir haben richtige investigativ Journalisten.
Das rettet die Demokratie.
Weißt du, was die rausgefunden haben? Die haben rausgefunden, dass die Linkspartei Insiderwissen an militante Gruppen verrät.
Oh
Weißt du, wo die Linkspartei.
Ich hab's immer gewusst, die Linken, ja, die unterwandern diesen Staat, ja, und das führt alles nur zum Umsturz der Revolution und es dauert nicht lange und wir haben das SED-Regime wieder. Ja. Das ist doch die klare Erkenntnis aus solchen Meldungen, oder?
Oder ist da irgendwie was anderes gewesen?
Was ist die also was kommt dir an der Überschrift komisch vor? Linkspartei verrät Insider wissen eine militante Gruppen. Über Bundeswehr, GSG neun und Rüstungsbetriebe. Welche Frage drängt sich die auf?
Woher wisse weißt du in die Linkspartei was da.
Für die Linkspartei Insiderwissen.
Insider. Bitte draußen bleiben äh Schildchen vor der Nase haben. Aber das ist wahrscheinlich in den Palenderparlamenten, wo sie irgendwie äh das Sagen haben, ne.
Bundeswissen.
Weißt du, wo sie das herkriegen? Über kleine Anfragen. Die stellen eine kleine Anfrage. Die gehen in die gehen in ein Parlament rein und stellen eine kleine Anfrage.
Fällt denen ein? Was? Die dürfen was fragen.
Dürfen sie, denn die kleine Anfrage als solches bezeichnet man eine auf wenige Punkte, begrenzte Fragestellung eines Parlamentariers an die Exekutive,
Beispielsweise eines Bundestagsabgeordneten an die Regierung, sie ist ein Instrument der parlamentarischen Kontrolle. Damit treiben Opposition, das ist Haupt,
eines der wichtigen Instrumente, mit denen Oppositionen arbeiten,
Damit machen die Parapiraten hier seit äh seit Jahren in Berlin oder seit Jahren, wie lange sind die jetzt hier in Berlin mit dabei? Drei, vier Jahre oder so. Seit drei, vier Jahren machen die Piraten gut, ihre kleinen Anfragen.
Und ähm auf Bundesebene sind's dann auch einzelne äh Abgeordnete, insbesondere der Andre Hunko.
Die wollen jetzt auch noch alles kontrollieren. Wo kommen wir denn da hin? Ja, da muss doch mal was gegen getan werden.
Genau, aber was passiert, was passiert ist? Jetzt geht der Andre Hunko oder diese Abgeordneten gehen hin und stellen eine kleine Anfrage. Das Schöne an den kleinen Anfragen ist ja, dass die Antworten dann veröffentlicht werden.
Vom Bundestag auf den Seiten des Bundestages. Dass die Antwort auf eine kleine Anfrage kannst du herunterladen von den Seiten des,
Bundestages.
Die stecken alle unter einer Decke.
Die stecken alle unter einer Decke. Der Bundestag macht quasi diese Informationen der militanten Gruppen zugänglich.
Also müsste man fast sagen, der Bundestag verrät Insiderwissen eine militante Gruppen. Aber was sind denn überhaupt diese militanten Gruppen?
Ja, keine Ahnung, weil, wie gesagt, weil wir haben sich halt um Militär gekümmert und weil wir ja in Deutschland irgendwann den den Anfang der Zweitausender auch mal eine militante Gruppe haben, die, glaube ich, auf irgendeinem Bundeswehrparkplatz mal einen,
Jeep angezündet haben oder so. Es mögen auch mehrere gewesen sein. Ich bin mit dieser Sache nicht so besonders betraut. Ähm.
Wurde das eben an die verraten. So, jetzt also kommen wir mal zum Punkt. Der äh,
Man kann als Parlamentarier, als und man macht es als Oppositionspolitiker natürlich eher als als äh als Regierungs äh treuer äh Parlamentarier,
Eine kleine Anfrage stellen. Da stellt man dann Fragen, die deren Antworten in der Regel wehtun. Zum Beispiel das Wissen darüber,
irgendwie bei mitgearbeitet hat, äh welche Firmen,
Das waren ja dann, wie ich auch in meinem Vortrag mal behandelt habe, eben die gleichen Firmen, die auch den äh Staatstrojaner reviewt haben oder an der Telekommunikationsüberwachung für das Bundesinnenministerium mitgearbeitet haben. Diese Information habe ich aus einer,
kleinen Anfrage,
der Linkspartei. Denn die Fragen dann und wenn es keinen Grund gibt, warum die äh Exekutive diese Information nicht rausgeben darf.
Dann äh macht sie das. Diese die Antworten werden, wie gesagt, auf den Bundestagsveröffentlicht sind für die Öffentlichkeit gedacht, nicht geheimlich vertraulich,
Und wenn es geheim ist, dann hat die Regierung die Möglichkeit zu sagen, auf diese Frage Antworten wir nicht. Jetzt gibt es aber einen äh Zeitraum zwischen,
der dem Erhalt der Antwort.
Anfragesteller.
Durch den Anfragesteller und die automatische Veröffentlichung auf dem Bundestagsserver. Und diese ähm.
Diesen Zeitunter diese Warteperiode gibt es.
Wird dann von den Anfragestellern häufig für die Pressearbeit genutzt. Dass sie also sagen, hier.
Da wird demnächst folgendes veröffentlicht werden.
Wir haben eine Anfrage, wir geben euch die zum Beispiel schon mal, also nicht selten wurde so eine Anfrage dann auch auf Netzpolitik org, äh früher veröffentlicht oder insbesondere auch früher angesprochen, als äh sie tatsächlich dann,
der allgemeinen Öffentlichkeit zugänglich gemacht wurde.
Ist wirklich geil. Also der Fokus wirft sich da wirklich mal so richtig schön in die Front, ja? Schön finde ich auch die Formulierung,
äh die Informationen seien an, man beachtet die Wortkombination militante, antimilitaristen,
herausgegeben worden. Was denn jetzt? Ja äh und ähm,
Ja, ja, aber hier Wolfgang Bosbach war ja gleich begeistert, ja, also der Verdacht äh gegen die Linkspartei würde sich ja äh bestätigen, ja, also dass die Informationen missbraucht werden. Also, was ein Prinzip sagt, ist
dass es nicht legitim ist, äh kleine Anfragen zu stellen. Ja. Ja? Und das äh ist doch mal wieder sehr äh fragw.
Und das in Zeiten, wo die Opposition, wie viel Prozent ist äh der Sitze im.
Ja und viele Anfragen jetzt auch wahrscheinlich gar nicht mehr so ohne weiter, also sicherlich also das Instrument kleine Anfrage,
Und auch große Anfrage ist, glaube ich, nach wie vor äh möglich. Das ist jetzt nicht das Ding. Aber wir haben ja, wie wir schon hier ähm in unserer umfangreichen Nachbesprechung der Bundestagswahl,
festgestellt haben, ähm die Situation, wo zum Beispiel die Einrichtung eines Untersuchungsausschusses nicht.
Möglich ist, ohne dass die Regierung selber der Meinung ist, man müsste mal einen machen,
sicherlich häufiger noch dazu führen wird, dass einfach keiner zustande kommt, wo sonst einer zustande gekommen wäre
Bisher habe ich auch nicht gehört, dass in irgendeiner Form ein Minderheitenrecht tatsächlich auch wirklich in Kraft gesetzt wird, also die Linken, Gisi vor allem, tja, mehrfach dafür ausgesprochen
die Regelung im Bundestag so ändern sollte, dass es nicht eine fünfundzwanzig Prozent Minderheit geben, also ne Entschuldigung,
Fünfundzwanzig Prozent müssen's mindestens sein, um einen einzurichten. So, wenn aber die Opposition geschlossen dafür stimmt,
dann soll es auch möglich sein, selbst wenn diese fünfundzwanzig Prozent Hürde nicht gemacht werden. Halte ich für eine absolute Diskussionswürdige Basis, so ähm,
Rechtsaspekte geben, die ich nicht überblicke, aber grundsätzlich gilt derzeit die Position ist halt deutlich kleiner als vierundzwanzig äh fünfundzwanzig Prozent,
und so wird es halt ähm zu diesen Kontrollmitteln nicht mehr so häufig kommen wie früher. Den Wert eines solche, so einer solchen Kommissionen kann man natürlich jetzt auch nochmal in Frage stellen, aber,
brauchen wir jetzt nicht.
Ja und bei den kleinen Anfragen, ich denke, das ist also man könnte, wenn man, also da die Linkspartei seit oder jeder, jeder Oppositionspartei, seit jeher den ganzen Tag nur kleine Anfragen stellt, so ungefähr.
Ist vor allem auch nicht so, dass die CDU das nicht tun würde.
Ich frage mich, was ist denn, wenn also,
Ich bin mal gespannt, was wir da noch bekommen so. Also, ich denke, das war der Auftakt zu irgendetwas ähm,
Da wird noch mal irgendwas zukommen, wo was diesen Artikel
jetzt in eine andere nochmal in eine in die richtige Perspektive rücken wird. Warum der jetzt kommt und warum der ausgerechnet jetzt kommt gegen wen da jetzt gerade äh gegen wessen unliebsame Veröffentlichungen da jetzt vorgegangen werden soll?
Da bin ich mal gespannt, aber da wittere ich wirklich jetzt die Verschwörung.
Da bin ich sehr gespannt.
Die Verschwörung.
Und wo wir beim Thema Verschwörungen sind, eine schöne Verschwörung,
ist jetzt, glaube ich, bald in der, in ihrem Untergang und in ihrer Auflösung begriffen. Da geht's um die Redtube-Abmahnung. Da hat jetzt eine Zivilkammer des Kölner Landgerichts ihre eigenen Beschlüsse revidiert.
Guck an.
Und ähm,
Beschwerden stattgegeben gegen dieses Vorgehen der Abmahner und das heißt, ähm dass es quasi ein Beweismittelverbot gibt für die IP-Adressen,
eben mit Hilfe der Täuschung oder der unzureichenden Erklärung gegenüber dem Landgericht Köln von der DAK AG ermittelt wurden. Das heißt, das dürfen sie nicht nutzen und damit ist dann eigentlich jede Abmahnung,
die irgendjemand jemals bekommen haben könnte von von diesen Leuten auch hinfällig?
Das heißt, diese Sache hat jetzt ihr Ende gefunden. Würde ich jetzt mal so.
Zumindest für diejenigen, die erstmal abgemahnt wurden, da weiß man ja jetzt auch nicht, wie die im Einzelnen reagiert haben, kann ja durchaus sein, dass da manche auch schon gesagt haben, hier nimmt mein Geld, aber lasst mich in Frieden, das was dann auch wieder alles äh.
Ja, das ist natürlich blöd, aber Lokbuch-Netzpolitikhörer haben ja von vorneherein gesagt bekommen, dass sie da bitte nichts hinschicken sollen. Und äh sind jetzt also äh haben jetzt bestätigt bekommen.
Genau. Aber ich bin doch betrogen worden. Ja, haben sie denn nicht ein Logbuch Netzpolitik gehört? Selber Schuld.
Noch kurz dazu ich, es ist äh kommt ein Beweismittel äh Beweis
Verwertungsverbot, sonst kriege ich wieder Ärger mit den Juristen. Ähm die Kammer hat angedeutet, dass ihre Entscheidung auch Bedeutung für ein Beweisverwertungsverbot in einem Hauptsache,
Prozess haben könnte.
Ja, das Schöne daran ist, dass, sagen wir mal, grundsätzlich hier ähm so ein so ein kleiner Sündenfall ist, sodass man künftig,
Ich weiß nicht, ob man wirklich davon ausgehen kann, aber ich halte es zumindest für äh eine gesteigerte Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass jetzt bei Gerichten dieses ganze Durchwinken von solchen Behauptungen deutlich kritischer gesehen wird.
Ja, interessanterweise da, genau das sagen sie sogar hier. Die Kammer hat die Kammer,
hat die Abweichung von ihrer ursprünglichen Entscheidung damit begründet, dass im Auftrag der DAKG von Download im Antrag, Entschuldigung, im Antrag, ähm der DAKG von Downloads die Rede war, während es sich tatsächlich,
wie sich später herausstellte.
Um den Abruf von Streaming, von einer Streaming Plattform handelt. Das ist natürlich spannend, weil dieses dieses Wort Download, ja, in diesem technischen Gutachten, was da dieser,
Anwalt formuliert hat. Wir hatten das, glaube ich, vor zwei Sendungen besprochen.
Wenn das ausreicht, um irgendwie so einen Richter zu überzeugen, ne. Also ich meine, dieses dieses Gutachten war ja sowieso unter aller Sau, weil es ja in keiner Form darauf eingegangen ist, was da überhaupt äh stattgefunden hat. Das wissen wir bis heute nicht,
die das gemacht haben. Und da bin ich wirklich, wirklich, wirklich, echt vorsichtig, wenn ich mir überlege,
sich ja doch als Bürger dieses Staates irgendwie sehr viel auf den Rechtsstaat halte und irgendwie auch auf Gerichte. Also ich denke so, ich meine,
Gott bewahre, dass ich jemals irgendwie vor einem Gericht landen muss für irgendwas, aber dann würde ich ja hoffen, dass mir da ein Gericht ein Richter gegenübersitzt, der wirklich ein Interesse hat, sich mit Sachverhalten auseinander äh zu setzen, bevor er da irgendwie seine heilige Entscheidung zutrifft,
und ähm das war jetzt da offensichtlich in Köln,
nicht wirklich der Fall. Da haben sie ja wirklich die, das war ja sehr offenbar so ein klassischer Fall von Anwälte Fluten die Richter mit Dingern, diese die die äh die die Richter irgendwie da im Akkord ähm abstempeln.
Ja ja, der Richter Vorbehalt schützt uns vor allen.
Das Weite ist also in dem Fall ist ja kein Richter vorbehalten.
Nee, nee, aber das ist ja das beobachten. Da gleich als nächstes äh ins Grübbeln kommt, weil grad's eben so dieses Interpretieren von äh technisch komplizierten Gründungen, ja, oder auch sicherheitstechnisch,
komplizierten Sachverhalten, wo vielleicht nicht unbedingt alle Informationen vorliegen
dann irgendwie Richtern zu überhelfen, die dann teilweise mit solchen mit der Bewertung solcher Situationen hoffnungslos überfordert sind. Ja, entweder weil sie nicht genug Informationen bekommen, falsche Informationen bekommen und es einfach auch selber gar nicht ähm,
überprüfen können. Ja, ich will den jetzt gar nicht so großen Strick daraus äh drehen. Vermutlich sind sie da wirklich im besten Gewissen vorgegangen,
Nur müssen sie halt jetzt feststellen, dass äh bestes Gewissen eben nicht ausreicht. Also eine gewisse Sensibilität in Juristenkreisen äh bezüglich dieser Grundproblematik. Ähm das wäre schon sehr wünschenswert.
Als Ergebnis hier rauskommt, inwiefern das dann sich in Realität umsetzt, das werden wir dann sehen.
Durch hier mit der einundneunzig.
Ja, tu die hundert rückt in greifbare Nähe.
Bin ja mal gespannt, was du mir.
Malzahl. Ja, da bin ich auch gespannt. Tja, keine Ahnung. Ähm greifbare Nähe heißt in zwei Monaten, ne?
Müssen wir uns mal langsam was drüber äh was an Gedanken drüber machen, was wir vielleicht machen möchten.
Na ja, wir sagen dann mal tschüss. Tschau, tschau. Bis bald.
Ciao ciao.